- [Narrator] What we have depicted here is
a signal transduction pathway
that gets started with the cholera toxin.
And we've talked about
signal transduction pathways
in other videos, but it's really this idea
that you would have molecules
outside of the cell that would
interact with receptors
on the surface of the cell
that would then create a
whole chain reaction of events
that would cause that
cell to do something.
And so what's happening here is,
if you were in the unfortunate situation,
and this is not something
that you would wish on anyone,
if they were to have the
cholera bacteria in their gut,
so let's say that this
is the cholera bacteria,
that cholera bacteria in your
intestines will release the,
what we can call the cholera toxin.
And here it's depicted
in very abstract fashion
by a circle on top of a triangle.
That's not what it actually looks like.
It's a protein complex with
various protein subunits.
It's just drawn this way
so that we can think
about this triangle part
interacting with this receptor
on the epithelial cell.
And so what happens is this cholera toxin,
it will interact with
this ganglioside receptor.
You don't have to know the details here,
really just the idea of what's going on.
And then once it does that,
when you see these arrows
on these transduction
pathways, you could view it as
that is going to activate the next step,
or sometimes you might say
might promote the next step
or make it more likely to happen.
But what then happens is, is
once this thing has interacted,
the A part of the subunit goes in,
interacts with a G-protein.
You don't have to know
all the details here,
but G-proteins are
something that you'll see
in a lot of signal transduction pathways.
There's not just one G-protein.
There's a whole family of
proteins called G-proteins.
And you can view them
as molecular switches.
They can get turned on and off
based on how they're interacting
with other molecules.
Their conformation, their shape changes,
and so that might activate
or deactivate them.
But you can see, you
can follow these arrows,
and you can see what eventually happens.
And you don't have to
know every detail here.
Eventually, it leads to adenylate
cyclase, then cyclic AMP,
then the protein kinase gets involved.
But the end result from this
pathway is that you have
these ions being released
from this epithelial cell.
And with that, that causes
the water to leave the cell,
and that's what causes diarrhea.
So the toxin gets your gut cells,
gets your intestinal cells
to start releasing water,
so then you're going to have
very, very, very bad diarrhea.
So that's the big picture,
but now we can think about
what might happen in certain situations.
So if I were to ask you,
let's say this epithelial
cell somehow had a mutation,
so its ganglioside receptor
does not interact well
with the B subunit here,
with the cholera toxin.
What would happen then?
Pause this video, and
try to think about that.
All right, so for whatever reason,
this epithelial cell had
a ganglioside receptor
that was a little bit different,
and it couldn't interact
as efficiently with the cholera toxin.
Well, in that situation, this,
this activation would not be happening
or at least would not be
happening as efficiently.
And so someone with that type
of a ganglioside receptor,
there might be some other
negative side effects,
but they actually would
not get as bad diarrhea
from the cholera toxin
because this whole signals
transduction pathway
would not be happening or would
not be happening as strong.
Now on the other hand, it turns
out that there's molecules
that can disrupt this
signal transduction pathway.
So what we have right over here,
this is an opioid receptor.
And if it gets activated,
then it will activate another G-protein.
This one is different than the one here,
but it's part of that same family.
And when you see this type of thing,
when you see a line with this
flat head instead of an arrow,
that means it's inhibiting that process.
So for example, this opioid
receptor is receptive
to a molecule known as enkephalin.
Once again, you don't have to know that.
But what you should know is that, okay,
you have this molecule outside of the cell
that can interact with
the opioid receptor,
which will then activate a G-protein,
and what's interesting
is that this G-protein
is actually an inhibitor of
this step right over here.
And so if you have cholera
and the cholera toxins in your gut,
but you also expose those
epithelial cells to enkephalin,
well, that might make the
diarrhea a little bit less bad.
Because if this gets disrupted
or at least if it gets inhibited,
then the rest of this
pathway will not happen,
or it will not happen quite as strong.
So that leaves another question.
If there was some mutation
in the opioid receptor here,
so it wasn't as good at
binding to enkephalin,
what would be the end result?
So if your opioid receptor is somehow
not as receptive to enkephalin,
well, then enkephalin
will not be as effective
at being able to stop this
signal transduction pathway
because the enkephalin
will not be able to bind
with that opioid receptor.
And so this inhibition will not occur,
and so you would just have the
regular transduction pathway
from the cholera toxin occurring,
which results in diarrhea.
So I'll leave you there.
The big thing to appreciate is
when you see these pathways,
arrows you can view as activation,
or they're leading to the next step.
And these lines with these flat heads,
this is about inhibition.
And it's pretty typical to see questions,
and, especially if you're a scientist,
you might construct these pathways.
But you'll also get questions on,
hey, if there's a mutation on something
that is activating part of
the pathway, what will happen?
And then the pathway won't
happen as much or maybe at all.
And if there's a mutation in something
that inhibits the pathway,
what would happen?
Well, if there's a mutation
that makes something
that would regularly inhibit
a pathway less functional,
then it won't be able to
inhibit the pathway as much,
and so the pathway will be less inhibited.